Let me tell you something.
A lot of people use their work,
their business,
their profession,
their success.
A lot of people use their pursuit of
education.
They're professional students.
You've been in college for 30 years and
you just keep taking more and more
classes and courses and more and more
and more things.
Or you work overtime under time,
side of the time,
around the time.
A lot of people are church addicts.
Every time it turns open,
you're not just a member of the church
who don't just come to Bible class.
You're in the choir and the usher board
and the praise team and the willing to
fried chicken committee and the this and
the that and the other,
and let me tell you something.
If you succeed in every area of your
life,
if you succeed,
you got the best help.
You're in the best safe,
you're the best looking.
You have the most formidable
personality.
You're successful,
you're financially secure,
you're respected every time you woke up
down the street.
If you succeed everywhere else and fail
to have peace and joy and love in your
home,
what does it profit you to have all of
this stuff allow outside and have no
place?
Yeah,
to lay your head,
to rest your mind,
to know that this is solid and this
won't shake and this won't bring it is
very,
very important to you.
Fucks us.
Whenever they sense danger or trouble or
become a weary,
they always go running into their holes.
That is a safe place.
That's a secure place.
He's grounded there.
Whatever's going to come,
I'm going to deal with it because I'm in
a place of grounding.
You understand what I'm saying?
Birds of the air have nests.
They say,
I know there's a lot of things that one
of the environment I want to get me,
but if I could make it to this nest,
I could get in this place where it is
difficult to get me if my nes is solid,
if it's secure and I had the bill list
mess,
I had to work on this nes.
So all of you who say you don't
understand my situation,
you don't understand my house,
you don't understand what I've been
through.
You don't understand my circumstances.
No,
you don't understand that nes must be
built from broken branches.
If you can build a whole mess from
broken branches,
you can reel a whole house with broken
people,
but it's gotta be built.
The problem today is we want prefab
houses.
It's easier to go get somebody else's
husband
then it is to develop.
See,
nobody wants to do the work of building
the kid.
They want to scream at the child,
they want to beat the child,
they want to yell at the child,
but the child has learned a lot of that
behavior from what was a model in front
of them and you have to get down all the
ground level wherever they are.
Even if it's a juvenile detention
center,
you got to go where they are and start
building that child block by block by
block.
Wild people were talking about you.
Well they're criticizing you while
they're saying,
where's your garb?
I thought you were a Christian.
You don't have time to worry about what
people think over outside because his
family thing is too important to,
for me to be yelling back at my
neighbors.
I'm trying to build something out of
these broken pieces that God has given
me.
Oh,
glory to God,
where my parents said,
what good is it to build a house?
If you lose the trial,
build the child.
The child will outlast the house bill,
the child,
the child will take care of you when
you're all bill the trial.
I'm over broken.
I know the crazy.
I'm only got them new beers.
I know the question.
Now I know you feel like luck big,
big,
but when you get to feeling like,
man,
get down on the floor and start building
them because you can have a mess if you
can't work with broken branches,
broken husbands,
broken wives,
everything in your house has cracked
somewhere,
everything crack somewhere.
Look around this room right now.
Look around this room.
Look at how handsome,
good looking and attract.
These people are in this room.
Both they look good,
dressed up,
got her hair done.
Look at the males.
Males all shined up pointing that you
had math nights.
Smeal like a Rhoda did from
just wonderful glory to God in that
wonderful just to him,
everything you'll see it's cracked
somewhere
and the only reason you don't know it is
because you haven't got close enough to
see where the cracks are.
These three areas,
Bill,
that puts you broken down.
You got to have economic support.
You've got a heavy Kebab and support.
I know you all think that once you're a
Christian,
all you have to do speak in tongues of
weight on Jesus.
The Jesus bus is going to come get you
and take you to be with Jesus,
but while you're waiting at the bus,
you're going to get hungry.
When I got rid of talk to my wife about
life insurance,
she said,
I don't want to talk about it.
Okay,
I don't even want to talk about it.
I don't want him up discuss it with you,
but that's all here.
We're going to have to discuss about
this.
She said,
I'm going to leave you.
I'll leave it too cause I ain't gonna
care.
I'm going to be crazy.
I said,
you're going to be crying and you're
going to be hauling and you're going to
be screaming,
but you will have to go to the bathroom
so you will need toilet paper.
You won't get thirsty.
So he couldn't leave water.
She didn't leave.
He will get hungry.
So you've got to meet food and if we
don't have no gas or you're not going to
be a bleed,
I have never seen anybody so brief,
but they didn't go to the bathroom and
eat and live and breathe and it's going
to bring you back to reality.
You need stuff.
You can't pray it away.
Your need for stuff.
You come up,
put spiritual solutions over practical
mean,
okay.
You cannot fix a physical problem with a
spiritual solution.
Sisters,
more Jesus say they'll make you more
wife.
I want to go to a text.
They're having a discussion and the
texts about if you get first timothy
five seven if any,
provide not for his own house,
for his own,
and especially for those of his own
house.
He has denied the faith.
He has been not faith.
If you don't take care of what yours,
you have the
faith
and is worse been then bill.
Yeah.
When you look up the word infidel,
you will find that it means unbeliever.
Okay?
But if you dig deeper,
you will find it is not just an
unbeliever who could have never been
exposed to the gospel.
If somebody who's been exposed to it and
rejected it
my best.
Thank you.
Somebody who's been exposed to it and
rejected it is called an infidel.
You'll notice in the conflict with isis
and terrorists,
they refer to us as infidels because the
purest form of the word infidel,
it's a to have rejected the truth.
Okay?
In the Bible,
women call somebody and infidel it is
that you had an opportunity and rejected
it.
Yeah.
And the text is talking about taking
care of widows.
And it says,
if the widow has a family,
if they don't take care of their own
mama and Grandmama opti big Mama,
my beer,
you are worse than an infidel.
Worse than an infidel.
If you don't take care of your own,
you were Berge take care of the old
monkeys.
Take care of the all frogs.
Take care of the whole,
and you will walk this role like you
don't know and say,
you love Jesus.
I'm really sees him.
Holy goof friend chicken and make up
some chicken noodle soup.
Then I would,
but I'm a prophet.
Test.
You're better profit.
Clean this house and go home and see
about Mama.
The Bible says you all wore spam and
bill.
Take care of your own house.
If you're able to.
Some people aren't they?
You don't have,
you can't do it,
but to some degree you do something.
You sweep.
Watch this,
and infidel is somebody who had an
opportunity to receive truth and
rejected it.
An infant of the Bible says you are
worse than an infidel if you don't
provide for your house.
All right.
God said you had the opportunity to make
that house work,
but you starved it.
You're worse than an infidel because you
were exposed to something that you
rejected though you stayed in the house.
Infidel.
Somebody say infidel.
Ooh,
infidelity.
Root word.
Infidel
primary meaning you rejected an
opportunity.
You know how you would judge it an
opportunity because you felt like you
were rejected.
You know why you felt like you were
rejected because she didn't get the
signal.
How do you break the infidel?
Infidelity.
When we start having real conversations
about expectations and responsibilities
mutually and you live up to yours and I
live up to my,
then there's not abandonment.
And if we're not abandoned then we don't
have to fake like we love each other,
which creates resentment because love is
hard to be fate.
So I will stop paying you money to let
me go live.
I will start investing because I will no
longer define myself by dollars
to the Potter's house.
He was so,
so a lot of times we give you stuff to
replace us.
You don't want to feel in this room.
Let me some tea when I fill in his room,
I feel in this room than there are a lot
of people in this room who have
abandoned kids cause he hurts you
parents cause they disappointed you
spouses because he didn't get the
signal.
I feel in this room a lot of people who
are still there but not there,
and so you live in your life like it's
golden.
Did might be golden,
but it's not grounded.
Yeah,
not grounded can blow away.
You can blow away and it's expensive to
lose it emotionally.
Mentally,
it's expensive.
Generationally.
I'm not saying you can't survive it.
I'm not saying you can't make it on
here.
I ain't got not saying you can't do it.
I'm not saying you can't pay your own
bills.
I'm not saying you can take care of
yourself.
You can do it,
but there will be a deduction.
Yes.
Once I start showing them miracles,
they're going to be drawn to my season
of miracles.
People are drawn to your season of
miracles.
Love your season of miracles.
You can make it happen.
You did,
Jill thing on the football fields.
Love you'll season of miracles.
People are drawn to your season of
miracles when you were in their heyday,
when did door and the old people love
you.
Phase of every car
always calls my hearing.
You didn't believe you were dumb to you,
heard you though you didn't believe you
could learn to your heard.
Somebody say you couldn't learn.
You didn't believe you want to a them to
your heard somebody say
your unbelief is the result of something
you heard about yourself,
that you believed about yourself and
your life has fulfilled the prophecy you
heard about yourself.
He'll crazy lakin daddy.
You had jess slack,
your mammy.
All of these are persists.
They may not be cussing,
but their curses that were pronounced
over you that said you couldn't do this
or that or the other and the more you
heard it and rehearsed it and even
argued about it and said you didn't
believe it,
every time you face a challenge,
tell me the truth.
Don't those voices come back up?
Every time you hit a low place,
those voices come back up again.
Every time things go wrong,
don't those voices come back?
You have never changed your belief and
you will never completely heal or hole
and to you change the voice inside of
your own head.
No body,
no body.
Ken Do this,
but you
new friends can't do it.
New Clothes can't do it more.
Mommy can't do it.
More women can't do it.
More sex can't do it.
They can camouflage it,
but the kid kill it because you are
snared by the words of your mouth.
You can't get him up.
People that tell you your privilege when
you think you're ugly,
that's why you keep needing some more
until you change the words that are in
your head.
Your opportunities will continue to
hemorrhage.
Like the woman with the issue of blood.
Her issues were killing her
12 years.
Her issues were chewing her 12 years.
The life's blood was hemorrhaging out of
her.
It was coming out of the lower
extremities,
but it was coming from her mouth.
Oh No.
The judge that
it is coming out of her lower
extremities,
but it is coming from her mouth.
Can you prove it?
Yes.
Okay.
What?
Heal her.
Good luck.
Calm football,
Lord.
It's treatment
came out of her mouth when she's sad.
Too Harsh.
See,
I'm till she met Jesus.
Oh,
she believed her mom herself was that
I'm dying.
I'm dying here.
And so her mommy died because she was
dying.
Hold on.
Relationships died because she was
dying.
Her heart was broken because she was
bad.
She couldn't have relationships.
She was dying.
She has spent all of her money because
she was dying.
Hey,
told,
it's how many but touch the hem of his
garment.
She didn't say it to anybody.
What she said to herself,
no,
didn't you read it in the original
language?
What is this?
She said to herself,
it says,
she said repeatedly to herself over and
over and over again.
Because when you're trying to drive out
stinken Benjamin,
you don't have to say it.
Oh,
and all that.
I'm a Hilton,
everybody.
So she says,
that's what I'm going to touch,
the hem of his garment.
I'll be made whole.
She took them over to a real family,
but touch the hem of his garment.
I'll be made in a hole.
So to even touch the hem of his garment,
I'll be made whole.
It's how many,
but touch the hem of his garment,
I'll be made,
touch the hem of his Karma.
That will be,
if I may,
but touch,
hi.
Hello?
Are you all crisis?
Okay.